what's up dude how are you I'm 2 chainz
Kyle how you doing what's going on with
this JIT surfing ok so this is the jet
surf adventure board this is the 2019
version this is a hundred percent carbon
fibre motorized surfboard underneath
that is the engine 100 cc gas-powered
two-stroke ok they're really big in
Europe and they're starting to get into
the United States a lot more there's a
lot of surfers out here in Texas
oh yeah Texas is a landlocked surfing
capital while Austin is a landlocked
surfing capital of the world
this is the adventure board so it has a
really nice department up here where you
can store extra gas so you can go
farther distances really so do they come
in different colors they also come with
no color on it where it's just a black
carbon fiber and you can also get custom
rat so you can get one that look just
like your jacket yeah this jackets what
it is fly yes sir
so how long have you been surfing six or
seven years but jet surfing probably
about three you consider yourself a
professional at this yeah so I'm
actually on the pro circuit and we raced
these professionally around buoys
against other racers so it's NASCAR and
f1 on the water give me a price for this
one is eleven thousand four hundred
damn that's a lot how much does our boys
normally cars you can buy surfboards for
three hundred bucks like a regular surf
and you won't this one's motorized and
goes 30 miles an hour
can't go 30 miles an hour and a $300
surfboard the Titanium's will go about
closer to 40 miles an hour those no
signal I'm sitting on that by I'm
standing on it no yeah and I'm doing 40
yeah you know I'm saying
but yeah I'm cowabunga
it felt longer you know we've got a wife
here I have great viewers here when they
want to see this thing work they want to
make sure they give me $7,000 work okay
yeah makes sense
I mean we got a wetsuit we can throw you
in the water and TV yeah I'm a baby
shark man and I've been swimming
underwater backstroker one has all the
diver be like I could do all of that
[Applause]
yeah so we got another pro surfer Dana
Lundqvist who is going to be
demonstrating for you on the race
titanium board Oh Dana Dana where art
thou Dana I think I'm ready to get me a
little preview all right I'm a new
surfboard Dana Dana in a world where all
the Dana's have gone missing get a 20 on
Dana
the inventors a mad genius where art
thou dana swarm of mechanical mosquitoes
about to attack e sometimes we fall and
you peod fine Dana
and it's cold as [ __ ] out here call this
[ __ ] I am but if you look deep in your
heart I'm over here you'll find all you
need is friendship and Dana where's Dana
hashtag words in the movie
[Music]
what's the surf thankful bring it in
yeah that's Dana that's Carlos what you
call it oh that's you and this mask
there's water you okay try to make an
entrance for you the way you did that
now some play on stuff you did man and
that's kind of like a held the ball you
had up there yeah yeah terrific
forty miles an hour let me see a little
bit mode name
I want one
yeah you totally should buy one I got a
liquor decree nice yeah I want one yeah
so you already know what it is we are
here in the middle of a place that God
made I'm with a man Kyle then they got a
great thing going with this jet surf
thing for 11,000 dollars you can get
your surfboard that goes up to 40 miles
per hour and you two can push your ass
like Dana beer out of here